hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we'll be taking a look at five Draco
Malfoy theories that have recently
caught my eye to start I'd like to
acknowledge that there are loads of
debates out there between fans as to
whether Malfoy was a redeemable
character or not there seems to be two
very distinct camps one that believes
Draco was a snake at the beginning of
the series and an even bigger snake at
the end and another that believes he was
simply brought up in an environment of
hate but was really a good person the
latter of these two groups suggests that
there is a very obvious character Arc
and redeeming storyline that Draco goes
through in the latter half of the series
I must admit that I'm somewhat with the
second group of fans and my beliefs
regarding Malfoy I'm sure he was a
pompous pure blood that did Terrible
Things to Harry and his friends and
their youth but these terrible things
were always done with juvenile intent
for example in the Philosopher's Stone
Draco was responsible for tricking Harry
into thinking he was going to fight
Malfoy in a midnight duel but his true
intention in challenging Harry was to
have him found outside of bed running
around the castle after hours something
which would have resulted in Harry's
expulsion expulsion not death not even
harm so I imagine you take my meaning
Draco seemed to hate Harry but not to
the point that he would cause him actual
harm at least as an 11 year old boy of
course later in the series there are
many times in which Draco is presented
with the opportunity to bring harm to
Harry such as when he was asked to
identify if a very badly stung Harry was
indeed the Harry Potter this happens at
Malfoy Manor in the Deathly Hallows
after a group of snatchers find Harry
Ron and Hermione in the woods and they
use a charm to puff up Harry's face
beyond the point of recognizability of
course the snatcher suspected Harry his
lightning bolts scar mainly to blame but
when Draco home from school on holiday
is asked to confirmed the puffy-faced
Adolescent wizard is the Harry Potter he
falters he knows it's Harry we know he
knows but he does not confirm it to his
father Lucius even though it would have
brought the Malfoy family back into
great favor with the Dark Lord because
Draco knows that if he were to identify
Harry as Harry he would have been killed
this is one of the most telling moments
to the true nature of Draco Malfoy and
so it's with this perspective that I'll
be taking you through today's theories
on Mr Malfoy 5. Draco helped Harry in
the Chamber of Secrets this Theory only
pertains to the movie however it's
possible that it was some secret
narrative in JK Rowling's mind as she
wrote the novel since she had a hand in
the films and was done to share
backstory with the actors and filmmakers
as necessary the theory stems from a
small moment in the movie that didn't
happen in the book when Harry Hermione
and the Weasleys went to flourishing
blocks to bind their textbooks and ran
into the malfoys Draco can be spotted
glancing around the shop to see if
anyone is looking before ripping a page
out of a book of course this on its own
means basically nothing but if you put
that together with the fact that later
in the Chamber of Secrets Ron and Harry
find a petrified Hermione with a ripped
page about basilisks in her hands one
may begin to see a connection the
obvious assumption that most people have
made regarding this scene is that
Hermione must have found information on
the Basilisk and torn out the page and
been on her way to find Harry and Ron
when she was attacked but when have you
ever known Hermione Granger to tamper
with the sacred entity of books I must
admit I do find it rather difficult to
imagine her doing something so careless
to a thing she held in such high regard
now back to Draco and his ripped out
page why would he have done this if he
wanted a page from a book surely his
wealthy father could have bought him the
whole damn thing well the theory goes
that since Lucius Malfoy had been
talking openly about the dangers
abounding Hogwarts for muggle bones he
must have been aware of or at least the
myth of a basilisk and other creatures
associated with Salazar Southern lurking
within the castle so perhaps in an
effort to learn more about what he'd
overheard his father talking about Draco
ripped out a page on the giant serpents
then when he realized just how much
danger the students at Hogwarts are in
he found a way to get it to Hermione for
her to share with Ron and Harry knowing
that they would try to stop it I suppose
there's always the more Sinister
possibility that Draco hoped the three
would go looking for the Basilisk if
they knew what to look for that is and
would then come to harm when they
encountered it 4. mere 7 Malfoy was
Hogwarts head boy I'll be the first to
admit that this is a rather benign
Theory however it's a theory nonetheless
in what would have been Harry Ron and
Hermione's seventh and final year at
Hogwarts there's the thought that Draco
Malfoy may have been the school's head
boy this role is typically entrusted to
a in your prefect which we know that
Draco was prior to his seventh year
there's also the fact that Hogwarts is
being run by Death Eaters at the time
and therefore Malfoy would have been a
suitable pupil to fill the role what
with his family's allegiance to the dark
lord do anyone who questions whether or
not Draco even attended Hogwarts in his
seventh year we know this to be true for
several reasons one of which is the fact
that Lucius Malfoy says to the werewolf
Grayback in the Deathly Hallows that
Draco is back from school for Easter
holidays 3. Draco was never a Death
Eater now since Theory number one in
this video was only really for the movie
franchise this theory is strictly for
fans of the novel if you've seen the
Harry Potter films then you will have
explicitly seen a dark mark on draco's
arm but in the books whether or not
Draco has a dark mark is a lot more Up
For Debate you may recall a previous
Theory I've discussed in another video
that Draco might have been a werewolf
and that the mark on his arm which in
the book Harry never got a good look at
was actually a werewolf bite from
greybank this is just one of many
theories offering alternatives to what
could have been on draco's arm if not
the mark of a Death Eater in my opinion
considering the direction and
allegiances the Draco chooses to make
after the battle of Hogwarts it seems
all the more likely that Malfoy never
actually pledged himself to Voldemort
making me quite open to the idea that
Draco was not an official Death Eater 2.
Harry was in love with Draco Malfoy in
the past I've explored the theory that
Draco was in love with or at the very
least had a crush on Hermione but this
is a new one for me apparently actor Tom
Felton the British actor who portrayed
Draco Malfoy in the series has said he
believes this particular fan Theory to
be true now I suppose Tom could have
been being glib since he says this in a
somewhat sarcastic manner alongside
Harry Potter co-star Rupert Grint who
played Ron in the series the two actors
laugh as the make the Declaration that
Harry and Ron must have been mad for
Draco with all the attention they gave
him the theory hinges on a similar basis
to the Draco was in love with Hermione
theory that because of all the attention
Harry gave Draco throughout the series
perhaps his strong feelings were fueled
by something other than hatred there's
also the fact that Draco was so easily
able to get under Harry's skin another
quality often associated with an
individual having intense unwanted
feelings for another now I'm not saying
that I accept this Theory to be true but
if it were I can see possible supporting
evidence in the way Harry behaved
towards Draco number one Draco Ron and
Harry are all distantly related now this
Theory makes the previous one a bit
awkward there are several fans out there
who have voiced that they believe since
there are only a limited number of pure
blood Wizarding families in the world it
would have eventually become impossible
to remain a pure blood without marrying
a relative however distant that relative
may have been
in reality there's actually more proof
to this Theory than just the
aforementioned speculation for cedrella
black was married to a Septimus Weasley
the two had three children one of whom
was likely Arthur Weasley who is of
course Ron Weasley's father draco's
mother was Narcissa black before she
became Mrs Malfoy and James Potter was
born from the black family lineage as
well but that's all together and we've
got Draco Ron and Harry all descending
from the Black family tree in one way or
another and with that we've come to the
end of another video what did you think
did I miss any theories about Draco
Malfoy that you think are worth
discussing please share your thoughts in
the comments below and as always if you
enjoyed this video don't forget to like
it and subscribe to the channel until
next time remember it does not do to
dwell on dreams and forget to live
foreign